So remember that our goal is to maximize the amount of useful computation done per second,
and we've been talking a lot about optimizing memory access because that's usually the bottleneck for GPU codes,
but some codes, or some portions of codes, are limited by the actual computation,
so let's talk about optimizing compute performance.
This topic boils down to two simple guidelines: minimize time spent waiting at barriers and minimize thread divergence.
Now, we've already seen an example of the first optimization.
Too much time spent waiting at barriers prevented us, in our tile transpose code,
from making memory accesses fast enough to saturate global memory bandwidth.
By shrinking the number of threads in the thread block,
we're able to minimize the number of them that were actually waiting on the barrier
and get closer to fully utilizing the global memory.